تفضل لا شكرا عندي الم في اسناني من
الصيام صح الصيام ما العلاقه بينهما وهل
واجهتم الم الاسنان اثناء الصيام ما وجهت
ممكن كل رمضان
هناك علاقه وثيقه بين الم الاسنان
والعادات المتبعه في شهر رمضان المبارك
نحن بنفطر دائما على المياه البارده بعدين
ناكل الاكل السخن ويشوف انه في عنده الم
بالاسنان بعد الافطار هذا غالبا سببه وجود
تشققات على السطح الخارجي للاسنان هذه
التشققات اذا تعرضت لاست لاي رد مفاجئ
ممكن تؤدي الى كسر الاسنان بالنسبه
للاشخاص المدخنين بدخنوا بكثره بعد
الافطار هذا عم يؤدي الى ترسب التصبغات
بشكل كبير وتؤدي الى تخرب اسطح الاسنان
وتحولها الى الاسطح خشنه يؤدي الى تراكم
بالجراثيم عليها النقطه الثالثه دائما
احنا بعد الافطار اذا تناولنا للحلويات
بكثروا على البكتيريا بتتكاثر بشكل كبير
وهذا ايضا يؤدي الى الام خصوصا بعد شهر
رمضان المبارك في عنا عاده سيئه بتصير
برمضان وبضلنا نايمين لعند الافطار اذا
كان هناك بقايا من الطعام حوالين الاسنان
اذا نحن ما نظفنا اسناننا بشكل كبير عم
يؤدي الى تحول هذه بقايا الطعام الى احماض
حوالين تؤدي الى نخر الميناء ونخر السطوح
الخارجيه للاسنان والتهابات اللثويه
بعد الافطار نزيف باللتي عم يحدث بسبب هذا
النوم الطويل نصيحتي الكم الاسنان
لمده ثلاث دقائق واستعمال الخيط السني
والخيط المائي والتاكد ذهاب الى عياده
طبيب الاسنان والتاكد من حاله الصحيه
لاسناننا وكل عام وانتم بخير